[Applause]
chief our interest
NBC's on assignment with Richard Engel
please welcome Richard Engel
[Applause]
what a dangerous job you have where have
you been lately that you're so thankful
you're back from Iran I've spent a lot
of time in the Asian Gulf actually you
were talking about climate I just got
back from Iceland and I was standing on
a glacier
and it was melting beneath my feet yeah
I was watching the water just drain into
the into the land I know somebody just
went to Alaska and said we wanted to fly
over the glaciers and they said it's too
hot
yeah so one one glacier there in Iceland
is dead it's gone and I spoke to the
leading environmental scientists in the
countries that all of them are gonna go
is that even if we did all the things
that are proposed right now the inertia
of what we've done so far is already too
much that the glaciers there are all
gonna go have a great weekend everybody
yeah well no we have to talk about that
stuff but let's talk about where you
have been I was a white supremacist
neo-nazi rally one day or another piece
of good news yeah related to the
conversation or covering it I assume yes
yes so I was at a neo-nazi rally right
in Germany of all places and oh I
thought they couldn't have them in
Germany no they can but you're not
allowed to display a swastika you can't
do the open handed salute Wow so all
these people this was a really ugly
crowd they had this plastic or tattoos
but they cover them or they take a magic
marker and they fill it in so it doesn't
look like a swastika and they do a
closed hand salute instead so the
interesting thing related to this
conversation is as I walked in and all
the other people walked in they were
handed a red baseball cap yeah oh yeah
and I spoke to the international symbol
now and it said mugga on it of course
not mag not the US make Germany hate
again well and this was just you know
recently well a lot of Europe has change
I know that's something you also cover
we were talking about immigration a
minute ago I mean even Hillary Clinton
said Europe has to get a handle on its
immigration I mean many people who are
not conservative people have made the
same point that the reason why so many
of these nationalist parties are rising
is Europe
it's because the citizenry doesn't think
that the Liberals can protect them from
a kind of immigration that would
inundate them well there is this this
theory it's actually a theory that
unites all of these shooters that are
across the u.s. that are opening fire
and the right-wing movements in Europe
and if they call it the great
replacement there are articles written
about it in a lot of newspapers and it's
a it's a conspiracy theory that says
that there is a plot by industrialists
Jews and others to take all of the
people from the from the Muslim world
from the non-white world and send them
up to Europe in the United States in
order to destroy the existing system and
this concept has been written about in
the in the manifestos that have been
published and it is the same kind of
thing that we heard at this neo-nazi
rally and it's the same kind of thing
you hear in a lot of mainstream
right-wing politicians so it's about
anti-immigration and then you take it a
little bit further and you say ah it's
not just about uncontrolled migration or
immigration it's a plot to destroy
civilization as we know it and therefore
we need to fight back and open fire and
shopping malls in schools well I there
have been some I thought positive things
I've read in the news lately about the
Arab world three countries in the North
Africa Algeria Tunisia Morocco ban face
veils which six European countries have
done 66 percent of 18 to 24 Arabs say
religion plays too big a role in the
Middle East
wow that's what I've been saying
seventy-nine percent say the Arab world
needs to reform its religion and last
week in Saudi Arabia they changed the
law a woman does not need a guardian to
leave the house
I must say the fact that that gets
applause is the very definition of the
soft bigotry of low expectations what
I'm watching more closely in in the
Middle East at the moment is I think
there's a real possibility that there
could be some sort of low-level conflict
with Iran and while there's some social
changes going on in the Arab world
because there's more authoritarian
regimes frankly returning there are also
there is this danger that the situation
in the Persian Gulf which is already
dangerous one one could say we're
already in a very low-level conflict
could escalate a couple of notches
because Iran feels it has been forced
into a corner the sanctions are on it
our people our star player people are
yeah are struggling to survive there's
shortages of medicines and what do they
have to lose it that's that's exactly
what it comes to there are people there
are hardliners who want this conflict
outside of Iran and there are some even
in ER in Iran particularly in the
Revolutionary Guard who say we're dead
anyway if we do nothing the sanctions
will kill us so we may as well try to
not they don't want a war necessarily
but they want something that will change
the dynamic and then they look at
history they look at Saddam Hussein
Saddam Hussein's Iraq and they saw what
happened to Anna Ron fought a war a very
bloody war with Iran yeah so they know
what what a tough enemy Iraq was and
then they saw what a decade of sanctions
on Saddam Hussein's Iraq did by the time
the u.s. invaded the army didn't work
the soldiers did the weapons didn't work
nothing the country folded in 21 days so
they think if we do nothing we're dead
anyway look at what happened and now
they an hour ran has Iraq
you